la eurocámara ha dado luz verde
definitiva a un conjunto de leyes muy
ambiciosas en la lucha contra el cambio
climático que buscan reducir al menos el
55% de las emisiones contaminantes en la
Unión Europea de aquí a 2030 una de las
leyes clave es la que obligará a las
empresas de la industria a reducir un
60% sus emisiones contaminantes y además
tendrán que pagar una tasa determinadas
compañías para compensar la emisión de
dióxido de carbono que provoca la
fabricación de ciertos productos para
evitar que estas empresas se marchen a
otros países con la política climática
mucho más laxa se hará la misma
obligación para las empresas extranjeras
tendrán que abonar una tasa igual que
las empresas europeas si quieren vender
sus productos dentro de la Unión Europea
los sectores que se van a ver afectados
serán los del cemento los del aluminio
los del hierro también los fertilizantes
y también las compañías aéreas que hasta
ahora estaban exentas según esta medida
va a poder incentivar a que otros países
del Mundo puedan seguir el mismo camino
y aumenten también su ambición climática
este nuevo paquete de leyes se espera
que se pueda ratificar en los próximos
días por parte de los estados miembros y
pueda entrar en vigor en las próximas
semanas en la Unión Europea además a
petición del parlamento europeo se ha
creado un fondo Social para el clima en
que ayudará a empresas también a
familias y personas vulnerables para
hacer más justa la transición ecológica
con un valor de un total de 90 mil
millones de euros